I just want to give you a bit of a sort
of background underneath this so do you
understand what this is about and
understand how to interpret it okay
because you're going to be doing a lot
of solving equations so you want to know
like what it's about uh what is it
equation lets you see what is an
equation
well it's got the it's got that of that
prefix in it right you you a which comes
through the word equals right so an
equation is a statement it's a standard
but it's not just a nice day but it's a
standard things that are equal right
which is why an equation to be an
equation it has to have an equal sign so
the question is a statement about things
that are equal so why is this come under
the topic of algebra right well we could
say an equation is a numerical statement
and we know tons of these right really
basic ones just with numbers so first we
could say 2 times 3 equals 6
that's a statement about two things that
are equal 2 times 3 is the same as 6
right or maybe clear 6 times 1 just to
make it slightly more interesting okay
but the whole point of algebra is that
sometimes you want to work with numbers
but you don't know what they are and
that was our whole introduction to
algebra at the start of the year okay so
the idea would be something like this we
would say to whatever pretty boy you
like maybe something like T 2 T is equal
to 6 that is still a statement about two
things that are equal right it's just
that at the moment as the way it's
phrased we don't know what tears we'd
have to do some work on in order to
solve it okay in this case what would we
do if I wanted to know what he was what
could I do to both sides of the equation
so I could divide by two right there
that's that are using yeah I'll actually
get a right I know you could do it
directly but I'm going to write / - okay
now making a big point of this because
if an equation is a statement about
things that are equal
that's why if you do something to one
side you've got to do it to the other
otherwise they won't be equal anymore it
wouldn't be an equation you'll get
something else like an inequality or
something like that so the most frequent
phrase you'll see is solve this equation
but there are some other phrases that
mean the same thing okay so for instance
you might see the phrase determine the
solution right when I follow on from
this line you told me - / - right the
twos over here is canceled and 6 divided
by 2 of course is 3 right so T equals 3
is the solution to this equation
I kind of like to think of it like a key
they're kind of unlocks it and there's
all kinds of other keys like 8 equals 2
T equals 1 you can try it on this
equation but it weren't a lock because
it's not the solution
you get determined the solution
sometimes it'll be find the value off
and yeah it just depends on what you've
got it might be next could be a tape it
could be any pretty room you're like the
point is algebra like you've got
something you don't know what it is and
you want to work out how much how big it
is one last common phrases you'll get
which is very very similar to this one
here is evaluate or or find the unknown
okay so the unknown is whichever
pronumeral or premier rules you have in
there okay and evaluate just means well
actually literally means find the value
of okay so anytime you see any of these
phrases or solve equation that's what
you're after you kind of want to get the
pronumeral on its own one more should
add it make whatever x t s whatever
matter they choose make it the subject
an equation right it says this equals
this
so the subject of the equation is
whatever's there on the left hand side
in this case wow it really worked T is
the equation of the subject okay